it's time to je suis excité j'ai accepté
parce que le thème d'aujourd'hui me fait
kiffer aujourd'hui enfin ce président
qui s'appelle only in publique trade
spots ça vous gêne quand je l accent
anglais les français détestent que
d'autres français parle avec un accent
et rennes de tenter l'accent on aime pas
je vous la fais parce que vous êtes mal
à l'aise only in public transporte et
voilà ça dérange personne d'un coup que
ça soit vrai dit je laime parce que les
transports en commun sont probablement
l'endroit où il se passe le plus de
trucs étranges sur terre on peut le dire
sur terre encore une fois c'est un
subway dit un peu neigeux voilà je vous
partage mais tysabri dit perso qu'ils
font est comme vous savez on prend tous
les transports en commun bas il ya des
trucs cool
il ya un truc drôle ya des trucs badens
et ça cela ils dégagent au fleix bonjour
ça coûte 2 par les transports en commun
mais ça nous touche tous sur les prends
tous très souvent on les a tous pris
très souvent brefs let's go
mais regardez brassard ça sent l'uriné
la sueur mais les écouteurs de ce
monsieur forme une note de musique
une cette gracieuse et politique wahou
[Musique]
ce flou rizla va chez chanel j'ai eu un
flash qu'est ce qui se passe c'est un
challenge eux s'est fait peur lui
qu'est-ce qui se passe ouais visite hier
à eau ont vraiment on met les comédiens
del arte les gars tranquille je veux
dire on a envie de le caresser quoi je
devrais ya beaucoup de gens qui ont la
phobie des souris et des rats et je ne
vous comprends pas moi je vous le dis je
ne vous comprends pas c'est mignon merde
et même quand il est au max de sa
puissance du che est à peine au moment
où tu vas la rage et tu es mort alors
écoutez ça tombe bien avec d'autres j'ai
envie de parler que vous la danse et le
dos je vous préviens on va faire une
petite pause voix pour discuter j'ai
reçu un colis et deux dents il y avait
une souris mais j'avais pas commander
une souris une souris à l'animal sommes
pas là rien ne va danser avec des
quiproquos à fonder j'avais laissé le
carton de couloir pendant une journée et
un jour jumbo xxxxx exception et que
vois-je une petite souris une toute
petite souris qui en sort comme ça et
qui était toute mignonne je suis allé
leur maître loin de hore b c'était une
belle rencontre donc s'il ya le regard
cette ville où d'ailleurs gros big up
c'était sympa de que tu visites chez moi
ramener une télé dans le train
[Musique]
pourquoi tout le monde fait comme si
c'était normal c'est pas normal et ça
peut pas être des complices là il ya
beaucoup trop de genre dit quelque chose
ça me fait penser qu'à l'époque j'avais
ça aussi un truc prévu pour une sorte de
mallettes targuer j'étais un agent
secret en fait appelez-moi squeeze 007
c'est incroyable j'avais mal est dedans
y avait ma xbox 360 qui a été scratchée
à l'intérieur là il y avait un écran pas
très grand beaucoup moins grand qu'il
avait un écran et je pouvais jouer d'où
je voulais j'avais juste besoin d'une
prise quoi c'est fou non
ça n'intéresse personne cette palette
[Musique]
qui joue la musique
ayvaz le rejoindre il va le rejoindre il
fait de surprises et va devoir
improviser un petit boeuf
oui où ils étaient faits pour se
rencontrer ces deux là mais moi j'ai pas
ça moi j'ai accordé ou je sais pas le
binôme de cuivre j'ai l'accordéon balles
accordés m'a raccordé au plus tard on
prend pas les mêmes métro les gars je
vous le dis reprend pas les mêmes métro
à l'aéroport de madrid
aujourd'hui il joua l'oculus ils sont
pas tellement les couilles
il est chez il est tellement confiance
j'aurais tellement peur qu'elle vit en
face une blague ou me touche pendant que
suis là dedans ça me fait bizarre je
n'avais pas réalisé qu'un jour on
croiserait en public des gens qui sont
en train de faire de la vère je me suis
toujours dit que ça se limiterait aux
consoles portables au téléphone mais
dense avec maintenant via des boîtiers
de verre indépendant qui a pas besoin de
relier un pc c'est assez logique mais je
suis pas prêt à porter en public je vous
dis ans dans l'avion entre deux sièges
et un chien café s'attaque aux eaux le
voilà croyable que tu dois passer ils
t'envoient toutes ces bonnes zones tu
dois tellement bien dormir même pas
besoin du coussin de merde là moi j'ai
jamais eu de chien dans les sillages
devant fait j'ai eu le bébé qui pleure
beaucoup trop foire a cédé que devant
tgv ça
c'est une france propre réseau ils sont
bas les couilles et à tanger est pas
forcé à ces techniques là toutes les
fautes j'ai attendu milan j'ai la
corpulence pour faire ceci
ça c'est mort par exemple mais ça c'est
donc un grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités
oh non c'est les mecs déguisés en super
héros qui font des happenings un seul à
seul à y mettre mal à l'aise
attention mais lieberman a perdu de sa
splendeur soyons honnêtes on est dans le
marvel universe ce mets dedans 30 en
quoi il ya eu un bon les selles
[Musique]
la réaction qu'elle a fait surgir bon
les gars il faut qu'on parle je
comprends l'envi de faire des happenings
de faire sourire de proposer un petit
spectacle en échange d'une pièce et tous
ok frérot on prend pas les transports
par plaisir on les prend pour aller d'un
point a à un point b
alors non on n'a pas envie de voir un
spider man baiser le plafond du métro
c'est chiant
[Musique]
j'ai vu une calvitie sur la gauche se
trouve experts blocage pas du tout oh
non il y avait une enfant jus cela et
son père et rigoler film qu'à celui des
yeux merde
une bonne manière de commencer sa
journée
non au moins ça vaut tout le café du
monde là il a eu un pic d'énergie mon
gars il était au top derrière je suis
sûr qu'il a passé une bonne journée
après essayer d'emporter un huitième
dans le bus quoi alors en france sont
autant dans les murs les huitièmes et
aux usa d etienne c'est juste une
machine comme ça qu'est dans un commerce
et apparemment cet homme aime beaucoup
cette machine mais mec comment tu peux
voler un etienne et te dire je vais
l'emporter en bus il va rentrer non
impossible d'annoncer ciao
comment tu peux mais comment tu peux
voilà un truc si énorme comment tu peux
espérer que le gars du bus va rien dire
c'est incroyable possédant 8e
quoi il en prend particulièrement soin
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel j'en
ai vu les gars transportait des trucs
mais une oie frérot a fait fort un mec a
raté son train comment c'est rageant de
rater ton train surtout que c'est dans
90% des cas liés à ton train d'avant qui
avait du retard ou à ton taxi qui était
dans les bouchons ou je sais jamais
notre faute qu'on rate intra hockey
comprenait sa mère de sfr
gaza
à lui les possédés freeroll ils étaient
en retard parce qu'il était possédé pas
histoire de métro au tac sinon ils
essaient d'en porter un canapé en bus
non mais les gars arrêtez le but ce
n'est pas un camion de déménagement
merde vous voulez faire rentrer des
trucs tellement grandes en des puces
c'est quoi la prochaine étape
j'ai vu ce spyder n'ont pas encore un
spider man je vais finir par détester
spider man si vous continuez à dent
sinon il investit les cieux apparemment
c'est le même mec de la vidéo d'avant
mais quatre ans plus tôt il a vrillé
entre temps il est devenu s'est mis à
baiser le plafond - les gars je vous le
dis ça me met tellement mal à l'aise
quand il se passa en france ça arrive
très peu ça doit arriver une fois fin
j'ai dû voir ça une seule fois la
plupart des gaz des gens statique qui
joue de la musique ou qui font un truc
en étant statique mais ça j'ai envie de
devenir invisible je vais me transformer
en plafond de métro quand ça arrive
sebring tokyo je sais de quoi ça parle
tous les japonais prennent le métro
personne ne prend la voiture et même si
leur réseau ferroviaire est très poussé
ben ali à idées des fois y'a d'la du
trafic à mort quoi et du coup ils
veulent que personne ne rate son train
dont qui pousse il compresse les gens
dedans c'est incroyable la porte manque
de thé krasus c'est pas grave c'était
ouf met mais à côté de ça ils font tous
la queue en ligne devant la porte du
métro il est bien les gens descendent
sont vraiment très bien organiser quoi
mais lui vient d'animer les gars
incroyable excusez moi mais j'espère
qu'il est actée au mec il a une vraie
tête genre c'est fou ça c'est génial
c'est ce concept de on l'écrasé et c'est
ok quoi il ne peut pas ne pas prendre ce
train
nous devons le faire rentrer c'est votre
devoir
il s'est fait baiser ils l'ont
discrètement dégagé on va les japonais
il nostro pas fâché en fait il déteste
le conflit gens et donc du coup là oui
là il n'ya même pas 10 frérot tu
rentreras pas il a juste fait toi ça
saute en mode j'ai pas fait exprès de
faire sauter su se calculait achiou
c'est comme ça que les méchants dans
marvel sont créés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça serait d'horreur ça n'a rien à faire
dans cette vidéo
ça va vous entraînera à ac ou fsa c'est
trop marrant
bon cette année on n'a pas eu hélas le
jour d'halloween de prendre les
transports et de voir les déguisements
tout le monde et tout c'est hyper drôle
ça fait trop bas des tas l'impression
qu'ils sont comme ça que c'est dans la
vraie vie quoi là typiquement c'est un
gars qui rendent d'halloween effet
gigaba des [ __ ] diago
ligoté le s'il vous plaît il faut qu'il
sépare de cet homme pourquoi acheter une
batterie quand on peut taper sa tête
contre une paroi que tu m'étonnes qu'ils
deviennent des êtres qui ne ressemble
plus aucune émotion et qui sont non
vivant est ce que tu peux je comprends
je n'ai rien compris j'ai adoré mes
jacques rougerie
[Musique]
mais c'est dingue mais je pensais pas
que des gens régulièrement sous j'ai
réveillé par le claquement des portes du
métro vous souvenez l'image du lapin là
dans le métro cette image elle avait
marqué deux fois quand j'étais petit
j'ai jamais fait pas donc les portes du
métro eux ils se méprennent sur la tête
c'est bon et en des chiens qui jouent
nommé comment comment vous faites pour
avoir vos chiens en liberté dans l'avion
quand j'ai ramené natsu les gars la
france je parlais de bourg quand j'ai
ramené natsu c'était un calvaire j'ai
demandé aux gens pour moi si je pouvais
juste mettre sa tête en dehors de la de
saccage parce que la cage était trop
petite en fait pour lui pouvait même pas
se retourner et les gens étaient trop
cool autour pas de souci je me suis
embrouillé par le staff de l'avion
pendant tout le vol ces 12 heures le
japon de vol et eux ils ont trois chiens
qui jouent au milieu de l'allée merde
vous avez vu je me mets à râler en
vieillissant c'est chiant mais ces dames
c'est la fin de ce sobre est dit et je
vous dire j'ai envie de prendre un métro
là je m'insurge métro car qui va se
passer un truc de ouf que place qu'on a
vu pas du tout il a repassé au mieux une
petite agression juste à côté de moi ou
super j'espère que vous a plu je prends
très peu les transports en commun
actuellement parce que je suis très
proche de mon lieu de travail je sais
qu'à l'époque où je les prenais je
croisais certains d'entre vous et on se
faisait des regards complices à travers
la rame
c'était drôle méfiez vous si vous
croisez des spider man dans le métro ça
a l'air d'être les plus dangereux faites
attention
allez prenez soin de vous attribuer
[Musique]